stood I had a crack filling and they  took the filling out and the [ __ ]  smell came out of my mouth I was like  holy [ __ ] cuz there was an infection I  had a wound up getting a root canal it  put like you could hear it like pop  through and then just this [ __ ] [ __ ]  breath they take this breath my father's  found he was sleeping wife said you have  to go to the dentist  so why does your breath is so out of  control so apparently he had an abscess  a sac of bacteria in the back of his  mouth well when they took the filling  out and they popped by accident I never  have the balls to tell someone their  breasts want them to tell me your breath  stinks one cool thing about black people  they'll tell you if